here all of a sudden i mean who among us
hasn't thought about jason miller in a
brazilian prison i mean that
you know that sounds about right
that sounds about right
[Music]
jason miller that chinless [ __ ]
pay your [ __ ] child support jason
miller pay your [ __ ] child support
you goddamn deadbeat that's all i gotta
say i figure that's why he was trending
because he's a [ __ ] deadbeat dead
but he's whining imagine
imagine
a [ __ ] trump humper a [ __ ] trump
ally whining a right winger oh
i've got it so bad
they held me
they helped me for three hours can you
imagine three hours waiting at an
airport for three hours
being asked questions
oh my god
have you guys seen the um the kathy
griffin griffin uh special
hey kathy griffin if you're out there on
twitter
um
her her newest special and i forget what
it's called off top my head
but uh
kathy griffin's new special like when
she did the whole um photo shoot where
she had like a mask of trump do you guys
remember this and she was holding the
head up and it was all bloody and stuff
do you remember that
and then and they they just i mean they
really they really came down on her
heart everyone came down on her heart
but
like she would go overseas and like they
would they would pull her in and
question her because she was on a watch
list you know she's on a [ __ ] watch
list because because of trump
but but the point is is that jason
miller is whining crying and i'm sure
i'm sure
that he thought it was hilarious
hilarious that kathy griffin had a big
question i'm sure
at airports but he was questioned for
three hours
and then eventually released he must be
a political prisoner
that's what they're [ __ ] saying okay
so number two is anthony fauci
anthony fountain